I wanted to start by saying that I feel
very lucky and grateful to be able to
study and teach science as my job and
one of the nicest things about it is the
opportunity to talk to people about
science so thank you to Kurt for
organizing this and for inviting me here
and thank you all for choosing to spend
your Saturday here I'm grateful to you
for coming so I don't usually do this in
science talks but Kurt said that it's
normal in these talks to describe a
little bit about how how one became a
scientist and so I'll start by
describing a little bit about my
trajectory from being your age if you're
young to being my age which is less
young and give you some just some
details about how that happened and
really it's you know I'll tell it as a
story about me but it's definitely
possible because of you know a few very
thoughtful mentors and people who just
helped me out in one way or another
along the way the bulk of my talk though
will be about some really peculiar
mysterious aspects of the laws of
science as we know them today these are
mysteries that people are still
scratching their heads about that Albert
Einstein spent his entire life
scratching his head about and that we're
still turning over and over and trying
to understand better so I'll tell you
about my work which is experiments I
work in a lab with real bits of
equipments like you were seeing
demonstrated out there and we try and
use things like those demonstrations to
learn more about these mysterious
aspects of the laws of physics so to
start with I have to put this in
so to start with Kurt gave you a quick
description of where I went to school
but I wanted to go back a bit further
and talk a little bit about the things
in each of those phases that eventually
sort of nudged me in one way or another
to become a scientist I went to public
school on the island of Martha's
Vineyard in Massachusetts from
kindergarten through tenth grade and I
would say there that I was not
particularly interested in science I was
not doing experiments I'd never seen any
of those things that you guys just saw
out in the hallway
I think the interests of mind that
eventually over the years morphed into
an interest in science with an interest
in like science fiction in spaceships
and aliens and Star Wars and things like
that and fantasy and even Dungeons &
Dragons and games and things that seemed
fun and back then they seemed fun to me
but in thinking about how this evolved
into a career in science I think that
what science fiction and fantasy
provided was an experience where you
could think about things that no one had
ever seen and things that no one had
ever done but which were possible which
are allowed by the laws of nature as we
know them maybe nobody's built that kind
of spaceship but you know you could
imagine it and in particular in Dungeons
and Dragons which is much maligned in
some quarters what I would say in its
defense is that it really reinforced
that idea and it's a game that's based
on telling stories about a world and
what can happen in those stories are
tightly constrained by a set of rules
and those rules are partially strict and
partially random they partially are set
in stone and partially they depend on
the role of dice and if I had to come up
with a succinct description of physics
it wouldn't be so different from that we
get to think about the world and things
that no one has ever done but if we can
think about things that you could do
that nature doesn't forbid we can think
about how to try and make them real so I
think those the ideas that sort of
morphed into being interested in science
but it wasn't until the last three years
of high school I went off island to a
private school nearby
and there had a really fantastic physics
teacher just for one year a guy named
Rodney Labrecque and he was a good
teacher because when we asked him
questions in class sort of why questions
he would answer so if if he was talking
about how atoms absorb light and certain
kinds of atoms only absorb absorb very
certain colors red or blue if it's this
kind of that kind and we would say why
you know he would pause for a minute
because it wasn't really in the lecture
and he would tell us about how well the
electrons that orbit around and the
atoms are really kind of like waves and
but they're kind of like particles too
and we would ask him why and he would
say well quantum mechanics and we would
say why and then also because he was a
good teacher he would say I can't tell
you today we have to get through the
lesson plan but here are some books that
are written for people who aren't you
know professional scientists they're
popular books and they talk about all
this really cool weird stuff about
whether the things around us or waves or
particles or how the universe really
works and here are some of the ones that
I read when I was in high school they're
definitely designed for a general
audience and I could recommend them I
went to college at Cornell University
and there I would say what happened is
that I got trained in the the real
practice the day to day tools that
scientists actually use and this
involves a bit of math and a bit of
physics physics like you would learn in
a classroom
and I would say that in my talk today
there's going to be zero math there's
going to be zero equations I'm gonna try
and describe everything just in plain
English just using words but to be a
scientist at some point you do have to
learn the the tools the mathematical
tools and stuff to do the work so and in
the course of that I got introduced to
sort of these mysterious questions about
the laws of physics in a little bit more
formal books which are still you know
readable for people who have a little
just a little bit of background after
that I went to graduate school so when I
was in high school I thought that
graduated school was the dumbest thing I
had ever heard of like you go to ok
college for another four years I can do
that but then really I'm done we have to
do something with our lives but if you
want to be a scientist it turns out you
need
more education than just what you
learned in college so I went to the
University of California at Santa
Barbara and one thing that I would say
about this is that if you go to business
school or law school or medical school
it's very expensive and if you want to
do it that's great and it should be part
of your dream but if you want to study
science College is like regular College
but the Graduate School for becoming a
scientist is free and in fact you get a
small salary for studying science and
this is something I had sort of no idea
about until I was applying for graduate
school so that was a nice surprise when
I was in graduate school this is when I
started to really learn how to do
research how to do experiments that no
one had done before and specifically
what a lot of what I learned was how to
use the same kind of tools that are used
to build computer chips circuits to make
really tiny little things so this is an
object carve out of a block of silicon
that has all kinds of little tiny wires
and these are little diving boards that
hang off the end and they're very
sensitive to any forces on them and to
give you a sense of the size here this
square is about the width of a human
hair so if there was a human hair on
here it would be incredibly long but it
would be as fat about as this square and
um on these little floppy hanging off
things I learned how to make thousands
and thousands of little metal rings and
there's a reason for all of this none of
which has anything to do with the talk
but I learned how to make some really
really neat little devices then in
science after you get a PhD you get a
temporary job usually called a postdoc
and I did this at at Harvard and MIT and
that's me younger and students who I
worked with and this is the giant
complicated experiment that we built
together and I'm not going to talk at
all about it but this was a period where
I got to work for three years not as a
student but as someone with a job doing
science and trying to learn new things
about the world so after this that's
when I came to Yale in 2004 and I guess
what I would say is this is the track
that brought me to Yale it was really
this kind
curiosity that was fired by the
imaginative arts and that's I got to
make contact with a bit in terms of
science where I learned that there were
still really big mysterious basic
questions about philosophy in the world
and how it works and gradually got to
learn about how to use the tools to
explore even more deeply these questions
okay so that's kind of my story very
abridged and edited and all that kind of
stuff I did have a question for you guys
though I just thought I would start by
taking a poll suppose that you had a
choice of having a pair of glasses that
were just regular glasses most of the
time but whenever you wanted they could
be the world's best telescope like this
kind of super telescope or that's one
choice or you could have glasses that
whenever you wanted could become the
world's best microscope and you could
see tiny things and whatever you wanted
so those were your two choices there for
free it's just a question of what you
think is more interesting who would pick
the telescope who would pick the
microscopes okay so when I was a kid I
would have picked another this matters
but when I was a kid I would have picked
the telescope now I would pick the
microscope the other question is suppose
that you were free to have a time
machine that could take you back to any
time on the planet Earth any historical
period dinosaurs Vikings Tutankhamun
whatever you wanted or you could have a
spaceship that could take you anywhere
in the universe to any planets that you
wanted again they're free it's just a
question of what would be more exciting
to you who would rather have the time
machine who would rather have the
spaceship okay so pretty even I mean I
hope we can all get along
okay so this is the story that I told
you about and what I'm gonna talk about
now is my research but the topic really
is one of these mysteries in the laws of
physics
it's a mystery called the wave particle
duality and I will explain to you what
this is so some things are waves in
nature the some things are particles and
when I say a wave I mean something that
spreads out through space and sort of
goes up and down and if I say a wave
what can you think of that you think of
as a wave I saw your hand first
yeah any others yeah so wave on the
surface of the ocean is spread out over
a huge area and it goes up and down the
sound from my voice spreads out through
this whole room and we can't see it but
it is that atoms jiggling back and forth
that's a kind of wave one thing about
waves is that they can be big tall or
small or anywhere in between so if I'm
making sounds with my voice it could be
really quiet I could make a quiet sound
or I could make a little bit louder
sound or I could make a really big sound
waves can have any size particles are
things that are in a spot in just one
spot and move around or whatever and you
either have one of them or you have two
of them or you have three of them and so
an example of something that's like that
I would say as a ping pong ball I can
have one I can have two I can have three
I can't have one point one ping pong
balls and if I throw a ping pong ball
into the crowd I didn't bring one but I
probably should have if I throw a ping
pong ball it will hit one of you but not
all of you whereas when I talk you know
my word doesn't just hit you and miss
everybody else the sound from my voice
reaches all of you so that's what a
particle is and that's what a wave is
and so here's an example of how to tell
whether something is a particle or not
start with a source of those things
ping-pong balls or sound or electricity
just spraying out here it is source
spraying out stuff light or sound or
water waves or anything and have a
detector that just collects that stuff
and if what I send out
particle like a ping-pong ball and my
detector records the location of every
ping-pong ball so suppose it's a piece
of sticky paper double-sided tape every
ping-pong ball that sticks to it sticks
and stays there and then I can look and
I see oh there was one ping-pong ball
and there's another and there's another
and there's another that tells you that
ping-pong balls are particles suppose
that I'm talking about something like a
wave like sound then I would just put a
loudspeaker here and I would put a
detector here like my ear that's a good
detector of sound and I would say where
do I hear the most sound and as I move
my ear around I might hear a lot of
sound here and it might get quieter as I
go over and around but everywhere I will
find sound reaching my detector that
sort of tells you that it's a wave that
it's spreading out but there's something
else that waves can do that's really
pretty special and this is what I'm
gonna illustrate here so suppose that
you have a source of something that is a
wave like sound or water waves and you
put a wall in front of it but that wall
has two little holes and you each hole
has a door you can open them or close
them and suppose I open one door and let
the sound or whatever waves it is come
through then I'll get some sound waves
over here nothing surprising if I close
that door and open the other door I'll
get sound waves over here but the thing
that's strange about waves though it's
not that strange I'll show you a picture
of it in a minute the thing that's
special about waves is that if I open
both doors and let waves that have come
through this door and waves that have
come through this door fall on my
detector I actually get a pattern of
light and dark and light and dark or if
it's sound loud and quiet and loud and
quiet and this happens too once in a
while with sound but mostly we don't
notice it because these patterns are
clearest if the sound is a pure tone if
it's a pitch like a so if you've ever
had like a an alarm that's going off and
it's oddly difficult to locate where it
is because like you put your head here
and it sounds loud and then you put your
head here if it's a certain kind of
beeping sound it can get quiet and then
loud again this is the phenomenon that
we're talking about
it's called interference and you can see
it in any kind of wave so this is a
photograph of water waves
coming through a double-slit and here's
the pattern of the waves as they move
through there and what you can see is
that there's a smooth patch of water
here if I was to put a cork there it
would barely go up and down at all and
then there's a patch of water where
there's Ripley waves here a cork would
be going up and down
here's smooth water here's waves smooth
water waves smooth water waves
that's this pattern of lights and dark
and it's just what you get whenever you
have waves that emanate from two sources
at once and bump into each other it's
called interference and you can see it
on the ocean anytime you can hear it in
your with your ears so let's now take
something that we don't really know much
about something that we can't experience
directly with our senses like an
electron an electron is the part of an
atom that can hop off the atom and move
to the next atom and move around and
that flow is what we call electricity or
electrical current and you can't see
them but obviously they're around
because they're making these lights work
and they're making my computer work
they're giving us power and let's ask
whether they are waves or particles so
let's have a source of electrons and
send it through double slit and ask what
our detector sees so what I'll be
showing you now our real photographs
taken of electrons as they go through
such a setup through a pair of slits and
hit a screen where they each electron
makes a little flash of light so when
you do that
can you see sort of eight or nine or ten
little white dots on the screen here
each one of those is an electron that
started from a source gone through
something that looks like this and hit a
screen and each electron arrives at a
point and makes a flash and says hey I'm
here this electron ended up right there
so what are electrons then yeah
electrons are a particle so here's the
same measurement they just let it run
for longer and I should say that what
they're doing is they're shooting one
electron it lands they shoot another
electron it lands each the electrons are
going through here one at a time they're
just showing the first ten here and I
think this is the first hundred and same
story right there just
of them but then they let a thousand
electrons go through all one at a time
but this is where all thousand of them
have ended up and this is ten thousand
and this is a hundred thousand electrons
so what are electrons yeah
that's sure cuz each one is making a
little flash of light yep yep yes but
over here you see them do ya yeah
there's there's something kind of both
is happening right if you see flashes
they're particles they have a definite
location but somehow when I let a whole
bunch of electrons move through here a
lot more land here a lot less land here
and a lot more land here which is what a
wave would do so somehow electrons are
things that behave like particles some
of the time and like waves some of the
time and you could imagine such a thing
like a boat that's cruising along on the
surface of the water is a particle it's
a thing with a location but it's making
waves
maybe the electron is something like
that the conclusion that people came to
even a long time ago 80 or 90 years ago
when people first were doing these
experiments was it an electron behaves
like a wave whenever we're not measuring
its position and whenever someone or
anything measures its position it acts
like a particle and it shows up at one
spot okay now this might sound like a
pretty bizarre conclusion to reach some
you know unfounded bit of gobbledygook
but let's just admit that it's not at
least obviously wrong it would describe
this fact that each electron seems to
arrive at a point but on the average
where the electron ends up follows a
kind of wave-like pattern but can we
test this interpretation well here's a
way to try and puzzle out a little bit
more closely what's going on suppose I
do the experiment again but I I want to
find out which path the electron really
took if it's a particle it should you
know definitely go through this slit and
then appear or definitely go through
that slit
so let me shine a laser beam just pass
one of the slits and have a laser
detector over here and so if the
electron really passes through this slit
it'll block the laser light for a second
and this detector will see the laser
light get dim and that tells me ah the
electron went this way I caught it I
know which way it went and if I don't
see a little dimming then I know it went
this way so if you do that experiment
what you find is this the wave
interference disappears if you turn this
laser off the interference pattern
reappears here so again this is
consistent with the idea that the
electron behaves like a wave and does
interfering as long as nobody knows
where it is but this kind of measurement
learns where the electron is and so it
destroys the wave interference okay now
do I really have to talk about you know
measurement and is that really
fundamental I mean after all shining a
laser beam on this experiment maybe I'm
just kicking the electrons maybe the
light is just banging into electrons and
causing them to go in a different kind
of way so let me now imagine a slightly
more complicated experiments where I
have one laser beam going through this
path one laser beam going by this slit
so if this detector sees the light dim
for a second I know the electron went
this way if this detector sees it's
light dim I know the electron went this
way I do the experiment again no
interference because after all I just
added another laser so come on if
anything that should just make things
worse I'm really kicking the electrons
now of course they're getting confused
and not making a nice wave pattern so
the reason that I showed you this funny
experiment is now I just want to tweak
it a tiny bit and this is where things
should start to seem a little surprising
let me replace this detector here with a
mirror so now see what I've done I'm
shining a laser beam that passes right
by this slit hits a mirror and comes
back and passes by this slit now if this
detector sees a dimming it doesn't know
whether that dimming is because the
electron went this way and blocked this
beam or if the electron went this way
and blocked this beam a dimming event
doesn't tell you which way the electron
actually went and if you do this
experiment
the interference comes back so here are
electrons that are definitely getting
kicked by a laser beam but they're
getting kicked in a way that doesn't
actually provide you with any
information about where they are and
that doesn't destroy the interference
pattern so it's still consistent with
this funny hypothesis that the electron
acts like a wave as long as we don't
know where it is and this is a
measurement that doesn't tell you where
it is so the last thing that I want to
show which is to drive home even more
that this is a bit peculiar let's now go
back to the case where I just have a
laser beam going past this slit and I
have a detector here and I send an
electron through and if this detector
registers that the electron went this
way we throw that data away and we only
keep data when this detector says I
didn't see anything one second then I'll
answer your question so so if I throw
away all the data where that detector
saw something that means I'm only
talking about data where the electron
went through this slit here so the
electron never saw the laser beam I'm
talking about electrons that never got
kicked by this measuring laser beam and
what happens the interference goes away
why because not getting hits by the
laser beam provided us with information
it's kind of like a negative it's like
an OU measurement sorry that's a bit of
technical jargon so this is a situation
in which the electron never saw the
measuring apparatus but it knows that if
it had gone this way it would have
gotten measured and it responds
accordingly by having it's interference
disappear
I mean that they do this the way that
they move depends on whether or not
anyone knows where they are
so like if you're walking down the
street and you're going from you know
your house to school you walk along a
certain path and if someone is watching
you someone is you know a spy is like
hiding behind the dark glass watching
you you would walk on the same path
right that person is watching you
wouldn't cause you to go around the
block a couple of times and then go to
school electrons do that if anybody is
watching
if anyone's spying on the electron its
motion becomes totally different that's
how your hand so that's a great that's a
great question it isn't because they
actually feel the lights touching them
because here's a situation in which the
light doesn't I think really answering
that question would be hard for me to do
in this in this talk so let me do what
my high school physics teacher did which
is to say they're really great books
that describe this carefully and in
detail and here are some of them this
one you're welcome and then somebody
else had their hand up yeah
the light yep so this red light is a
laser beam like from my pointer here
which is green and I'm just trying to
draw it bouncing off the mirror and
coming back it does you're right it
doesn't really curve it just goes
straight and comes off but I couldn't
figure out a good way to draw that that
would be clear no that mirror doesn't
get broken all that happens is the light
comes and hits the mirror and comes back
so it's a way to get the light to take a
zigzag path and go through yep exactly
I'm gonna tell you about that I'm gonna
show you some pictures and I'm even
gonna pass something around that shows
you part of the experiment yeah how sure
are you that what you're what you're so
sure of it's not just an illusion it's a
fair question and let me partially
answer that in a couple slides read the
book yes but I know I'll give you I'll
give you a better answer than that okay
so hopefully this makes no sense to you
like this is not a behavior that we ever
see in the world around us there's
nothing that that does this but when we
do experiments on little tiny things
like electrons and atoms this is what we
see so the conclusion that I would make
is that the way that anything behaved
the way that the electrons that I've
been telling you about the way that they
behave depends crucially on who has
information about them and the laws of
quantum mechanics don't say this about
electrons the laws of quantum mechanics
unambiguously say that this is how
everything works the whole world around
us
like over here I think it would be the
same thing but basically any time the
light takes a zigzag path that goes past
both slits you don't learn where the
electron is and so you get an
interference pattern but if you come up
with some zigzag that only goes through
one slit then if it flashes you know
which slit the electron went through and
you get the not interference pattern
okay so this is the mystery about the
laws of physics as we understand them
that they tell us that everything in the
world acts this way and this isn't the
only weird thing that the laws of
quantum mechanics describe there are a
few others here that maybe I won't read
through but they're all described in
those books that I mentioned and what I
want to underscore is that there are
hundreds thousands of experiments that
show this you can if you probably not in
a high school lab class but if you study
physics in college and you take an
advanced lab class you will do
experiments that show some of these
things just on a you know tabletop here
with some simple lasers and simple
detectors but it doesn't just happen in
university labs you my computer your
cell phone the internet works because of
this this is how transistors work which
are the basic building blocks of
computers this is how lasers work which
are the basic building block of
telecommunications and every experiment
and every device and every product
agrees perfectly well with this theory
but the theory is mysterious to us
people are still trying to wrap their
heads around this we don't really
understand it very well and the thing
that I want to say is that all these
experiments and all these devices that
make use of these funny effects only
involve tiny tiny objects an atom a part
of an atom a bit of light and the
question that I'm interested in is since
these weird phenomena are generic to
objects regardless of their size so it
seems why can't we see them in the
behavior of large objects so here's a
line that shows you the mass or the
weight of objects and every tick mark is
a thousand times lighter so the average
person like Albert Einstein is about a
thousand times lighter than the average
wael and the pen cap is about a thousand
times lighter and a tiny bug is a
thousand times lighter and if you keep
doing a lot of thousand times lighter
you get to an atom or a proton or an
electron or neutrino tiny tiny little
particles and all these quantum
phenomena are readily observed in the
behavior of atoms and things like them
so people have done the kinds of
experiment that I told you about with
electrons they've also done this with
atoms and they get data just like the
electron data quantum mechanics says
that if you do the same thing with an
ant with a bunch of ants you should get
the same thing so if I have a slit and I
just drop ants through it
I should see the ants tend to end up
here and not here okay and I have an ant
problem in my house and so I've seen
ants do a lot of weird things but I have
never seen them do this and there's a
reason that's doesn't invalidate quantum
mechanics it's actually turns out that
quantum mechanics predicts that you
shouldn't see ants do this the reason is
the following if you take sort of
reasonable atoms and send them through
the tiniest
slits you can make these stripes on your
camera will be about point one
millimeters apart and a millimeter is
about the distance you can hold your
fingers apart easily so point one
millimeters if you have a magnifying
glass you can see that no problem
quantum mechanics says that if you drop
ants through the slits the distance
between these places with a lot of ants
and places with not so many ants is this
many millimeters which is something we
call a femtometer or an FM and it's it's
tiny it's it's smaller than an atom so
you would never notice that there were
slightly more ants here and slightly
less ants one femtometer over that's
part of the reason we never see these
things the other reason is that at room
temperature we're all jiggling a tiny
bit okay I just drank a lot of coffee
so I'm jiggling more than when I came
here but the air molecules around us or
zinging around in the air that's part of
just being warm and and a single atom
doesn't jiggle around so much at room
temperature that it would obscure this
but an atom at room temperature sorry an
ant at room temperature is jiggling
around by a lot more than one femtometer
so somehow you'd have to figure out how
to make the ants extremely cold
if you
even wanted to try to look for this tiny
difference the last point that I wanted
to make is this point about how any
measurements in the middle of this
experiment would destroy these features
and if you have an ant
that's very cold because you've didn't
you've taken care of that part and you
drop it through double slits if that ant
happens to hit an air molecule while
it's falling just one air molecule the
air molecule has learned where the ant
is and that will destroy this
interference pattern now atoms are small
enough and we know how to put them in
good vacuum in chambers with no air that
they can go from point A to point B
without bumping into a single air
molecule but with ants or Einstein or
blue whales that's just a lot harder so
this is why we tend not to see quantum
effects in everyday objects but if you
worked really really hard at all these
things you could you could see an ants
do this you could see your brother or
your sister do this that's at least the
idea that we'd like to test nobody has
done that so far
the world record for doing that is done
an experiment at the University of
Vienna in an experiment that looks like
this and basically what that is is a big
metal chamber that has all the air
removed from it that's all it is it's
about 20 feet long so it would fit on
this desk here it's an experiment that
two or three people run and it works in
this way at one end they have a source
of molecules bigger than atoms but not
big in our everyday sense these are
these experiments were done with
molecules that are made out of 60 carbon
atoms in the exact shape of a soccer
ball not because it's the exact shape of
a soccer ball but it's a cool molecule
nevertheless they're called bucky balls
and they go flying through the vacuum
until they come to a thing that looks
like this and i have one of these and
it's taped onto this piece of paper here
and I'll just pass it around it's in a
gel cap like a pill that you would take
but please do not eat it would be bad
for you it's a piece of silicon so it's
made out of the same material as sand
and it has a hole a square hole in its
middle you'll see this when it comes
around to you and stretched over the
hole is a very thin sheet of glass it's
a big sheet so it's a it's about a
square millimeter remember what a
millimeter is so you can see it with
your
but it's very very thin and this is a
picture of one of them and what they do
is they use these these tools that I was
describing that are used for making
computer circuits and they slice a bunch
of tiny slots in it and here's a zoom in
showing all those tiny slots that have
been sliced into one of these membranes
is what it's called and these slots are
so small that this scale bar here is one
fiftieth of the diameter of a human hair
so a human hair would be this big around
10 miles long and these are the little
slots that they cut and if you don't
can't see them here's another zoom in
showing the little tiny slots and here's
where you actually chop it in half to
get a good view from the side and this
is what they look like when you slice it
in half so each one of these bars is
just a few hundred atoms thick and this
is really at our limit of how big and
small we can make these things so going
okay good so keep passing that around
because I'm gonna have a lot more to say
about these little things so here is our
slit for the molecules to try and go
through and at the other end at number
three is a detector and this is real
measurement each one of these bright
spots is a buckyball molecule they went
through this slit and look they don't
come in a big beam so they're not just
waves but they still come with stripes
so they're not just particles each one
of these is a flash each one of these is
a single molecule so they're arriving
like particles but somehow their overall
pattern is as though they're waves
they're doing this wave and particle
thing at the same time even though
they're pretty big on this scale of
things so that group that did this
actually made a nice movie the each
little red dot appearing is one of those
molecules arriving at the screen and so
you can see at the start of the movie
it's very dim and they're only a few
molecules but as more and more build-up
you can see this pattern more and more
clearly so this is wave particle duality
in real life it's on YouTube if you want
to find it and this is the biggest
molecule they've done it with yet it's
800 atoms which is a big molecule if
you're a chemist but you know if you
stub your toe on one you won't notice
it's still too small even to see with an
elect
on microscope so that's the biggest
thing in which we've seen these weird
quantum mechanical behavior so in my
group we study how could we search for
quantum mechanical behavior and even
bigger things and the thing whose
quantum behavior we're looking for is
actually one of these nitride membranes
the same thing that our friends in
Vienna used to make their slits we're
not making slits with it we're not
shooting molecules through it we just
want to look at this thin sheet of glass
and how it vibrates and whether the
motion of that one square millimeter
object can do some of these weird
quantum mechanical things even though it
has a quadrillion atoms in it that's a
lot more than 810 and so far we haven't
been able to do the kinds of experiments
that show the wave particle duality
right away but we have been able to see
some simpler examples of quantum
mechanical behavior in the motion of
this one millimeter sheet of glass in a
thing that's very similar to what you're
passing around in the yellow bit of
cardboard so to explain how this works
which I can definitely do in the next 15
minutes let me ask a question about
sound so I said at the start because you
guys encouraged me that sound is a wave
fills the room I can make it bigger
louder or quieter but suppose maybe
sound is a particle sound after all is
the vibrations of air and what we're
going to be looking at are the
vibrations of this glass trampoline this
glass membrane so we could think of
those vibrations as sound they're very
similar and what we'd like to know is
are they waves or are they particles it
sound a wave whereas sound a particle or
is it going to be one of these cases
where it's kind of both so let's imagine
a box full of sound it could be a wooden
box that you shout in and the sound will
echo for a while or it could be a really
carefully made echo chamber where you
shout in at once and the sound lasts for
a long long time all those sound waves
bouncing around so if there's a lot of
sound in this box which we call a
resonator the sound waves would be very
tall and here's something that you might
not know but I just have to tell you if
light passes through something with
sound in it it can either add a little
bit more sound
where it can subtract a bit of sound it
can either add some sound or absorb some
sound as it passes through now if sound
is a wave the laser could make those
waves a little bit taller or a little
bit smaller in any amount that it wants
but if sound is particles the only way
that light can add sound or subtract
sound would be to grab one of those
particles or two or three but not 1/2 or
1/4 so if light comes through a box of
sound and the sound is made of particles
we'll only see it able to absorb or emit
sounds in little chunks now mostly that
wouldn't matter if there were a million
sound particles in your box and light
comes and removes one you probably
wouldn't notice it would look like it
was just getting tiny bit louder a tiny
bit quieter but suppose we come up with
a box where there's only enough sound to
make one particle in that case the story
for sound waves would be basically
unchanged light can come in and it can
make these little waves a little bigger
or it can make these little waves a
little smaller but if there's only one
particle the light is probably not going
to hit that particle and so it's going
to be very unlikely for the light to
absorb any sound but the light can
always ABB's
a sound particle so if sound is a
particle it will when that when there's
very little sound in the box light
passing through will find it easy to add
some sound but hard to remove some sound
yeah yeah so this is a sound that's
repeating itself and as it bounces
around in here it's repeating itself
even more so you would call this an echo
no light is made out of electricity and
magnetism it's a wave of electricity and
magnetism and you know that electricity
and magnetism pulls on us pulls on
everything and so when light passes
through air or glass or you or me it
pulls on us a tiny bit and launches and
causes vibrations and those vibrations
are the same thing as sound it does both
nope it can do either so light that
passes through so when this laser beam
is shooting through the air it is both
adding to the sound of my voice and
absorbing some of the sound of my voice
usually a net of zero
ah I'm gonna tell you that in the next
slide the question is how do you know
which one it's done so here's what we do
we're not going to measure the sound in
a box we're gonna measure the vibration
of a solid object that membrane so let
me start with a mirror and if I send a
green laser beam onto a mirror like this
one it bounces off green mirrors don't
change the color of light so if I
collect the light that's coming off the
mirror it'll just be the same green
light that I sent in but now suppose
that my mirror can vibrate here it is on
a spring it might be shaking back and
forth now when something is moving it
can Doppler shift light so I don't know
if you've ever heard like when an
ambulance is coming towards you the
sound waves get sharper and when it goes
past you they get flatter the same thing
happens with light if someone is running
towards you really really fast
they will look a little bluer if they're
running away from you really really fast
they look a little red you've probably
never seen this you have to be running
really really fast to change light but
it does happen a little bit and so if
the light happens to hit the mirror as
the mirror is bouncing back and forth
while the mirror is rushing towards the
light the reflected light will be a bit
blue shifted and if the light happens to
have hit the mirror when it was moving
back on that spring the light will be a
little bit red shifted so when we
collect the light some of it will be red
and some of it will be blue now if this
falls onto a detector that counts each
Photon some of those photons will be
green and some of them will be blue and
one thing that I haven't mentioned is
that a blue photon carries more energy
than a red photon so the only way to
turn a green photon into a blue photon
is to give it some energy well you did
that because the mirror hit it but that
energy had to come from somewhere it
comes from the mirrors motion that's the
absorption of a bit of sound the light
sucked a bit of energy out of this guy's
motion in the red case that bit of light
has less energy that's because the light
was coming in and it hit a mirror that
was going back so it almost comes to a
standstill
so if the light lost some energy that
energy must go somewhere it goes into
adding to this mirrors motion it makes a
bit of sound
so that's why it's just saying here each
time you see a bit of blue light you've
added a sound whether it's particle or
wave each time you see a bit of red
light you have absorbed a bit of sound
whether it's a particle or a wave and
the thing that I was telling you before
is that if there's a lot of motion here
both of these will happen about the same
amount so if there's a lot of sound
you'll see as much red light as blue
light if there's only a little bit of
sound but sound is a wave you'll see a
lot less of either but you'll still see
the same amount of red or blue because
you can take a little wave and make it a
little bigger or you can make it a
little smaller but if sound is a
particle and there are only a few
particles in there it's much easier for
the light to add a sound particle than
it is for light to find one of those few
sound particles and gobble it up so the
light will look like this so in our
actual experiments we do a couple of
tricks to make the experiment easier
than in this cartoon we add another
mirror to make sure that the light
bounces back and forth and here if
you've ever been in the lobby of a
business or a restaurant with mirrors
facing each other and you see a million
reflections of yourself that's what we
build so we trap light so that there are
a hundred thousand reflections in there
and then we don't have a vibrating
mirror instead what we do is we have
fixed mirrors and a vibrating membrane
that thing you're passing around that
thin sheet of glass but it's the exact
same story as this thin sheet of glass
vibrates back and forth it's doing this
so this is what the experiment actually
looks like there's one of these little
chips here it is in a photograph it sits
on this titanium stage that we build in
the machine shops here that stage gets
put inside this metal can the metal can
has mirrors on either side whose jobs
are to trap the light bouncing back and
forth and then this whole thing gets
hung from Springs inside of a special
refrigerator that cools it to within one
degree of absolute zero so inside a
refrigerator that's four times colder
than interstellar space yes
so it like it's in here because the
mirror like the light can get through
the mirror a little bit so when some
gets in here it bounces back and forth
each time seeing what this sheet of
glass is doing how it's moving and
eventually it leaks out either a bit
blue Doppler shift to the orbit red
Doppler shifted because the mirror the
membrane is always wiggling around in
there so we have to put it in this fancy
refrigerator because remember we said
that temperature was going to cause
things to jiggle around in a way that
would obscure things and we have to it's
also in a vacuum can to get rid of all
those air molecules that would be doing
all the measurements were not interested
in and our lab which is in the building
next door looks like this this is the
refrigerator you guys saw some liquid
nitrogen out there this is even colder
this is liquid helium and it gets us to
about one degree above absolute zero
this is a three thousand pound table
that floats on compressed air like an
air hockey puck and that keeps the
vibrations from the floor for messing up
our experiments this is what all the
lasers and mirrors look like it's
basically a giant erector Sattar Lego
set all these things put together to
steer laser beams around and then this
is the measurement yeah
in which slide oh so yeah this is just
this is making the laser light that
we're gonna send into the experiment and
pose your question no so we use
electrical currents to make the laser
light just the way this thing is doing
is using electricity from the batteries
to make laser light and the membrane
that might be vibrating that has the
sound in it lives inside this
refrigerator and we don't need to add
much sound to it it's already got
whatever sound it's gonna have in it so
this is the measurement so this is
sending in a green laser and seeing how
much red laser like how much of the
light comes out red and how much of it
comes out blue and from looking at this
I can't say that there's more of one
than the other but that's what we would
expect if there was a lot of sound in
the membrane and in fact quantum
mechanics would tell us that if we want
there to be only one particle of sound
in this membrane it has to be very cold
it has to be 33 millionths of a degree
above absolute zero so way colder than
our refrigerator can get or really any
refrigerator can get so since it's
thirty thousand times hotter than that
there should be about thirty thousand
sound particles in there which is a lot
of sound particles and so we wouldn't
expect any difference if the light comes
and gobbles up one or adds one so what
we do is we make the thing much much
colder one Kelvin for these experiments
is blisteringly hot one degree above
absolute zero is way too hot so we make
it much colder and to do that we shine a
laser beam on it and this is a totally
fascinating story that I don't have time
to tell you about but about twenty-five
years ago people realize that if you
take a laser and you shine it on
something like my hand it usually makes
your my hand hot but if you tune things
just right and the laser beam can pass
through the object you can play certain
tricks so that when the laser beam goes
through it carries all the heat out of
that object with the laser beam leaving
the object colder this is an amazing
thing called laser cooling we didn't
invent it but we make use
of it to lower the temperature from
thousands of microkelvin
to four hundred three hundred two
hundred one hundred million seven degree
above absolute zero
now we're getting definitely less sound
in there so we have to zoom in to see
what's going on and here's the
measurements as we lower the temperature
to 70 sixty forty thirty millionths of a
degree above absolute zero and now what
you can see is that we're seeing the
sign of it being easier for light to add
a bit of sound than to remove it and
it's happening when the temperature is
just cold enough for there to be just
one sound particle in there so one sound
particle is thirty-three microkelvin
here word about 29 so on average there's
a bit less than one and that's why
there's this difference I can show you
the same data again taking these red and
blue traces and just plopping them right
on top of each other so you can see even
when things are pretty hot there is a
little difference but the difference
gets bigger as we make things colder and
colder and that difference demonstrate
that the sound is a particle in the
sense that it can only be absorbed and
emitted in chunks
even though sound is a wave right it's
moving through the air and it's acting
just like a wave so here is a
demonstration that sound in this case
the motion of this millimeter-sized
object that some of you have held in
your hands and can see with your naked
eye is actually obeying the laws of
quantum mechanics yeah absolutely
so this is an illustration of what I was
saying way back when that all these
weird things about quantum mechanics
apply to everything around us but
usually the things around us are too
heavy and too hot and interacting with
too many air molecules for us to notice
it but if you're really really careful
and lower the temperature and get rid of
all the air you can't indeed see these
quantum mechanical effects in these very
large objects so this is the end of my
talk so just if you take anything away
it's that's the laws of physics we can
write them down we can write down the
equations but they tell us things about
the universe that are very weird and
that it's worth checking if they really
happen which is
we do experiments this opens the
possibility to doing things that no one
has ever done before using these laws so
nature tells us there are all these
things that we've never seen an object
do that they can do and we could
possibly use them for for technology to
benefit mankind and we would like to
learn how to do that in the case of our
experiments we were able to see these
quantum effects in something that is
this big it weighs 110 millionth of a
gram and the very last thing I just want
to do is to thank all the people who
work in my lab on these experiments and
they're the ones who really make the
experiments happen and thank you very
much for sticking around
[Applause]
[Music]
it's sort of depends what you mean by
discover I've definitely I would say
maybe more like invented I've and the
people that I work with we've come up
with new ways to make things work new
ways to measure something and I would
say you know this is an example of
uncharted territory people believed that
these laws would be true but no one had
ever seen an object this big do this
kind of thing I don't know that that's
exactly a discovery but it's it we've
we've added to I think people's
understanding of the world no I know
what I said yeah so this is all in the
science of physics which is how you
measure things how things move around
how things act when you push on them or
pull on them how light works how
electricity works yep
yes I mean so this so what I told you
about when I came to Yale this is what I
wanted to do in my lab and that was in
2004 the data that I'm showing you was
taken in 2015 so this was 11 years of
work of building we doing it wrong
300 times and each time you know
figuring out what we did wrong and
fixing that and then doing something
else wrong and forget for 11 years and
so we got it to work so yeah this is
built on a huge pile of mistakes yeah I
think that's a fair thing to say yeah we
found new ways of using using objects
and we saw things that nobody had seen
before they sort of knew it was there it
was like if you're you know sailing on a
boat and you see an island on the
horizon that's great
but we went there so we didn't discover
it but you know we sort of held it in
our hands for the first time
yeah
so when I was in high school and this is
a bit of a cheat this book didn't come
out until a couple years ago but it's
the kind of book that I wish came out
when I was in high school these were
ones that ya really sort of made me
realize that all the sort of mysterious
and amazing ideas that were firing my
imagination in this kind of stuff are
real like there there really is stuff
that seems like magic but as part of our
but as part of science so I would I
would particularly recommend these books
if you're maybe in high school or there
abouts but younger too if you want to
check them out
know two observations can cancel each
other and that's what we saw so there's
a so here's a situation in which sort of
two observations the laser goes through
and says hey was that electron here yes
or no and then it comes back and says
hey was the electron here yes or no and
then all it says to this guy is yes
there was an electron there but no if
you have two different observers you
can't play this game
not doesn't interpret this is nature no
not at all but thing it's not about
wanting or liking or disliking but
things do behave differently if they if
information about them has been acquired
and stored elsewhere that's maybe the
when we're saying it you can ask
[Applause]
[Music]